Oh world,
it's Raj.
And today we're going to learn how to
use a pretrained tensorflow model on an
android device. So this applies to
any device that runs on android.
We would train the model on our desktop
or on our laptop or on the server,
and then we would use that pretrained
model on our mobile device.
So there's no training that
would happen on the device.
The training would happen on our bigger
machine, either a server or our laptop,
but then the inference,
the actual making of making predictions
that would happen on our android device.
So that's what we're going to do today.
And uh,
we're doing it for a handwritten character
image classifier. So the user would,
here's,
here's what it looks like.
So you draw an image and then you hit
detect and it's going to output the
result. And the result is the probability
of what that class is. It's a,
it's a multi-class classification
problem. So it's a very, very simple APP.
And the point of this is to learn
how to use tensorflow with android.
Very simple use case.
Right?
And there are a couple other
examples that I'm going to give,
but in this example, uh, it's
just as simple as it gets.
So it's a great way to get started.
You can use this repository that I'm
going to link to that I'm going to be
looking at here as a base for any other
type of classification project that you
want to make. Cool. So
that's what we're doing.
We're going to write a handwritten
character image classifier.
The user draws it with their hand and
then he hits the tech and it's going to
classify it.
And doing this on a server or on your
laptop is good because training is a very
computationally expensive process and
it's a very energy intensive process,
right?
We can't just plug our phone into our,
into the wall all the time, but we
can do that for our laptop or desktop.
So that's why we do it on those machines.
But in France we can easily
do that on our phone.
So what I have here a is this little
architecture image of what this looks like
from a, from a high
level, we've got to, um,
we've got two repositories here.
We have the android Sdk,
and then we had the android n d k. Right.
So what's the difference here? Well,
the STK is a standard developing
kit and the MDK is the, uh,
native development kits.
What do I mean by that? Well,
the SDK has written in Java and
the Ndk is written in c plus.
Plus we use the Sdk as an interface to
code everything we want in Java at a high
level.
So that's all of the things that are
native to android activities and fragments
and image listeners.
So I'm going to actually go into quite
a bit of detail on how android works.
I'm not sure how much, you know, I've
never really talked about this stuff.
So rather than being a fly by,
I'm just going to go as detailed as
possible and hopefully, you know,
you don't already know all this stuff.
Okay.
So I'm just going to assume you don't
know much about android. So, uh, right.
So android has a very
specific way that things work.
This is very specific way that objects
interact with each other, right?
You have these activities and
then you have these fragments,
image listeners and all of these.
And then on click and create all of
these event listeners for how uh,
you would interact with an android APP.
It's,
it's specific to a
touchscreen like interface.
And so that's what the Sdk is good for it.
You can do all of that stuff in Java.
But what the NDK is good for,
it's for looking at or is for working
with c plus plus files and what is
tensorflow written in the core of
tensorflow. It's written in c plus plus.
So that's why we use it so we can look so
we don't have to deal with c plus plus.
That's why we had the SDK. But under
the hood, the SDK talks to the NDK,
which is written in c plus plus. So what
happens is you see these two arrows.
So this Arrow Arrow one
takes the image a bit map
image@theuserdrawsandsendsittothistensorflowjni.cc
class,
which is like the main tensorflow. See
a wrapper for android written in c plus.
Plus. It takes that image and it, it,
it turns it into a tensor.
So it resizes it into a tensor,
gives it to the model of the pretrained
model, which is a pro buff file,
which we'll talk about more,
but as a pretrained convolutional network.
And it's going to output the prediction,
which is a tensor to back to
that t plus c plus plus file.
And then that CPI plus file is going to
return a list of probability values in
the form of an rea straight to our SDK.
That is our Java class.
And we'll talk about all of these classes
in order from the highest level to the
lowest level. Uh, but that's, that's
essentially what it's doing here.
Okay. So that's the example
that I'm going to use.
But there are several examples
of how tensorflow can work,
can work with android.
So this one is probably the most
well documented one that I've seen,
but it's called android tensorflow,
flow machine learning example.
Basically it is a general purpose
classifier. So if you have a device,
you can plug your device into
your computer with android studio.
And then in real time is just going to
classify everything that you look at this
wallet, you know, 29% wallet.
That's a pretty bad classification
plan, present wallet. But Hey, uh,
20% ballpoint pen.
And the reason it's so well documented
is because it comes with an associated
blog post,
which has got all of these pointers
to work with Bazell and uh,
you know how to set up your workspace so
that it's pointing to the right version
of the STK and the NDK. Uh,
so yeah, all that stuff.
But the reason I'm not doing that is
because it is more complicated than what
we're going to do a, but
that's a good next step to go
to after you do this. Okay.
So that's the image classifier example.
There's another classifier
which is a little more detailed.
So it does the same exact thing as the
first, but once it's classified the image,
it then queries both Wikipedia and a
Wolfram Alpha for some more data about
whatever object it is. So it will classify
an image like let's say it's a lemon,
and then use the lemon as a parameter
when it makes an http request to the
server and then it returns a short
paragraph description of what a lemon is.
So you can see how this
can be pretty useful.
For now we're going to need the apps that
are actually useful to day to day life.
Uh, right. So there's that. And there's
one more that I wanted to talk about.
They're all really classifiers cause you
know you have the camera on the device.
So why not just classify everything?
I mean there's so many use cases for
classification that haven't even been
attempted before. It's such a, it's
such a broad application, right?
So this is guest sketch and there's
actually a web app version of this too.
But you would draw something and then
it would classify whatever it is.
So obviously you would need a model that's
trained on a lot of different images.
It's not just m and ist,
but like a lot of different images.
So that's when you do something like this.
Inception would be a great model to
use for this pretrained inception.
I love how they named it inception even
though it has nothing to do with the
movie, but uh, it works like a
dream, so, okay. That was anyway,
where were we? Okay, so we're
talking about installation.
So that's what we're first
going to talk about. So again,
remember I'm assuming you don't,
you've never used android before. Uh,
so if you have used android
before then just skip ahead.
Like I'm going to estimate four
minutes, but okay. So the first episode,
download android studio.
So android studio has everything you need.
So you know, there are several things
that you could use with android.
You can use eclipse,
the ide,
we could use android studio or you could
just use this with terminal and a text
editor.
But I'm saying that you should use android
studio because whereas before it was
super buggy, like when I was using
it a lot, a year and a half ago.
Now I just downloaded a,
and I've been looking through a lot.
It's actually really,
really good now.
Like it takes care of a lot of dependency
issues for you inside of the ide,
which is amazing. Uh, so you can
download it from here. It's got, it's,
it's available for all
the operating systems.
And so these three steps
are the next three steps.
And actually if you're
using android studio,
you can do it all inside
of android studio.
You don't actually have to
do this from command line.
This is if you're using
eclipse or terminal and a
raw text editor like sublime
or something. But you would download
the STK and then you download the NDK.
Okay. As well as the build
tools. And once you have those,
you would point those to the right.
You would point your workspace to those,
to the location of both. So
your app knows where to, uh,
where to find these repositories. Okay. So
that's what we've got there. And so in my
grade will file, I've got this, you know,
the target Sdk version so that I
know where that that's going to be.
Okay. And so let's see, what else
do we got here to properties,
local properties. Cradle is the
build system for android by the way,
UC use Maven, but now it uses
great old. So yeah, that's,
those are the dependencies
that we would use.
And then once you've
downloaded these dependencies,
then you want to train the model,
right?
So remember we train the model on a
desktop or on a server and we do that in
python just like you would even
if you weren't using android,
you would first train the model there.
So let's go over that.
What the python file looks like at a
high level and then we'll keep going with
the android app and the code,
the Associated Code.
So for the model in Python,
let's see what we got here.
This is what the model looks like.
So this is the care os version.
There are two versions.
We've got the care os version
and the tensorflow of virgin.
But I'm going to go through the
kiosk version really quickly. Okay.
So we're going to import tariffs and
Python. Okay. So once we have those,
we're going to build a
convolutional network.
A convolutional net is used
to detect images, right?
Humble show nets are used for any
kind of image classification or even
generation. We can use convolutional
nets for image generation.
We just reverse the way things work.
Like we would use gradient ascent or we
would slice off the last half and then
add some kind of ad is to cass tech
note in there. So it generates, um,
some novel data.
We would add a random variable in a see
variational auto encoders for how that
works.
But you can generate new data types.
And also obviously generative
adversarial networks,
which I've made videos on both of
those topics. See my you Udacity,
deep learning and a degree
course all on youtube. Okay.
So a couple of methods here. The first
one is to load the data. And this is just,
you know,
standard reshaping.
We have to remember we have
to vectorize our input data.
What do I mean by vectorize?
I mean,
we used to take our image raw image and
then convert it into a tensor format so
that we can feed it into our model.
And so in this case,
it is a four dimensional tensor,
right? So the length with, uh,
the size and the, the,
the depth, which is,
which is going to be one, right?
Because it's only a single layer image.
So we reshape it using numb Pi's, native
reshaping functions. It's a float 32.
So these are float 32. These
are 32 bits, a pixel values,
who an image and out of 255 possible,
uh,
and then we got out of 255
possible RGB values. And so once,
then once we have that, uh, vectorize,
we'll split it into a training and a
testing set. And that's it for load data.
And then for a model,
great thing about [inaudible] is it's
only a few lines and we can build a
convolutional network just like that.
It's going to be a sequential model
with three convolutional blocks.
So we do perform convolution,
which is essentially like taking a
flashlight over a filter of images and
looking for what sticks out.
So in this case it would be the Mni
is t the the actual digits, right?
Cause they're black on white background.
So it would detect, hold that.
And then we perform pooling.
So pooling is an operation where
we look at an image like an array.
So let's say you know,
we've got like four different,
we've got a square, uh, where you know,
each of the values in the array
represent is a different number.
And then we, for Max pooling we would
take the maximum value from that square.
So it's, let's say we
got like four, nine, 12,
15 we would take that maximum value,
which is going to be a,
so the Max value and that's you know,
a post you opposed to average pooling
or one of those, this is just a,
a more often used pulling
strategy. Okay. So I actually,
I already explained it so I don't
need to go that, go to that. Okay.
So we do polling and then we do it
again, again, perform convolution.
And what this is doing is every time
it's creating more images and smaller
versions of that image. Right? And
Yeah,
we keep doing that until
we're at the very end.
And now we've got this very high
dimensional four by four by 256 dimension
tensor. But we need, and how put
probability, right? We need an,
we need a prediction die.
You're already set up prediction values
for the probable classes multi-class
classification. So what will we do? Well,
we have to flatten that tensor into a,
a one dimensional array,
which is the list of probabilities.
So we'll,
we'll hit or flatten it and then we'll
add to fully connected layers to which
are the dense layers.
And uh, the last, uh,
activation will be a softmax function.
We're just going to output a single, uh,
value for each of the class outputs.
Okay.
So that's it for the model and then,
yeah.
Okay.
Okay. Thanks Internet. Okay.
So that's it for the building, the model
part. And then for training with care,
Ross,
remember it's just two lines.
We compile the model and by
compile we defined two main things.
We define the loss function that
we're going to minimize because it's a
multi-class classification problem.
We're using categorical cross
entropy and because it's an end,
what are we going to use to actually
minimize that loss? Or we're going to,
we're gonna use an optimizer,
a form of gradient descent,
which I have a video on called
evolution of gradient descent.
And we're going to use add a Delta,
which is an adaptive learning rates
gradient descent strategy. Okay.
And so once we have that, then we're going
to actually train the model, which is,
which we do with one line of fit function.
So in tenser flow,
this would be the akin to defining a
session if finding the grass and then
iterating through defining the for loop
where we iterate through all the batches.
Here we just defined the number of
batches as a parameter to the number of
epochs who do it all in one line and
then the training data as the input.
Okay. And so that's the
first key part is training.
And so the other key part is exporting
the model. So once we train it,
we have to export it. So we have to
export it into a Prodo buff file,
write a PD file,
PB file is a saved,
uh wait file that are
a model lives on that.
That is our train are trained model,
right?
So once we've tried on model model and
we save it as a pro but file so we can
then use it later.
And what is the protocol file?
Well it is a serialized version of our
model, right? With all of the Lord waits.
And so we do that in this method,
right?
And this is the way to do it for
android. Okay. So well actually this,
this can apply to any type of use case
but it is a general purpose saving
function,
right?
So definitely saved this function for
later use cause you're going to use this a
lot whether you want to use your model
on a server with tentraflow serving,
whether you want to use it
on Android, ios. I know Ios
has the, you know, the new,
um, what was it called? Cornell,
which is really cool and I'll talk about
that as well. But android is more used.
So I'm going to talk about android
first. So, right, so we write the graph.
Okay,
we write it and when we,
the right graph function is going to help
us define what we're going to call it
and then we do the actual saving
and then we freeze it. And what,
what do I mean by freeze?
Well,
freezing means we're going to save
our weights wherever they are.
So our weights are at a certain,
you know, they're all a certain,
they all have certain numerical values,
right?
So we're going to freeze them at
those values. That means it is,
it's essentially like saying a declared
these weights as constant, right?
So you can't change it that
they are immutable variables.
And then so once the weights are saved,
we're going to open it again
and then resave it, uh,
using this optimized for
inference function, which
saves it as float 32 values,
which are, which are the type of
values we need for android devices.
So that's why we save it,
open it, and then re save it.
And then we'll convert it into flow 32
and then receive it. So we do it twice.
Okay. And we on the second
time we save it. We,
we have it serialized two string values.
Okay.
So that's it for that.
And then for our main function,
that's where we call all of these
functions that we've just defined.
We make sure that there is no output
folder and if there is a, if there's not,
then we create one, we load up our
data, save it in these variables,
build the model,
train it on the data that we just load
it up and then export that train model
and then export that train
model using the tension flows,
native saver function and the
model has parameters to the uh,
ouch directory. And then we can use
that same model in Android, in an,
in our android happened. Okay.
So that's it for that part.
And so we've got that part and now
we're going to look at this bar. Okay.
So let's assume we've trained it.
We trained our model, it's, it's
saved. Now what do we do? Well,
we've downloaded our SDK and
our Ndk we need one more thing.
We need something tensorflow specific,
right?
The SDK and the NDK or
just a part of android.
They have nothing to do with tensorflow.
Remember up here, this, this,
this part right here with a tensorflow
underscore Jay and I that cc,
that is what Google made.
Google made this themselves so that we
can use tensorflow functions on Android,
on device.
So that's what we need to download.
And the way that we download this is to,
is to download an AA.
Our file that has an android Arcov
are archived file. So what is it?
This is a way of archiving
that dependencies,
all of those that we need into
a convenience, a little rapper,
like one file that we have to look at,
but under the hood,
inside of this file or all of the uh,
c plus plus files.
But we just don't have to look at them.
If it wasn't wrapped like this,
then we would have to look
at all the c plus plus files.
And we would use a tool like Baisil
to build all of them from source.
But the great thing about Aa harm is,
is that it is compatible with the
great old build system that is built,
that is made for android.
So we can just download it and then import
it into android studio and it's going
to know all of those files and it's good
to put them in the right directories
for us.
So,
so there's a lot of great magic
happening inside of Android Studio,
which is actually very useful,
right? It saves time and energy.
And I've linked to a tutorial
on how to import an AAR file,
which is very similar to a jar file.
So it made it and we would use a lot more,
we would use jars a lot more.
But in a grateful,
we use AAR files a lot more.
So yeah,
check out this tutorial on how to
do that. It's very simple. Okay.
So once we've done that, we've got
our tensorflow specific dependencies,
we've got our SDK or Ndk, we've downloaded
this repository. Once we'd done that,
we could just literally compile it and
run it on the simulator or the device if
you have one.
One of the reasons I chose this specific
repository to demo is because it
doesn't require a device, right?
Not everyone has a device.
You can do this in the simulator because
all of these classifier examples that I
talked about,
like this one and this one,
and this one require you to have a
camera and you can't use a camera on a
simulator, right? You
need the actual device.
It will be cool if you could
use a Webcam and, but you can't.
So this is the most accessible
a repository that I could find.
Okay, so let's go over the
steps in this tutorial.
So what are we going to do here?
We've talked about the python
file and how that works.
Now let's go into the
android specific codes.
So we're going to go into android studio
and go from a high level to a low level.
So we'll go, we'll, we'll,
we'll go down two paths.
The first path we'll go down is
the actual visualization path.
So we'll start at the main activity and
then we'll iteratively go down the chain
of dependencies, draw, model,
draw a render, and then drop you,
which is the lowest level of
what's happening. And that's
the draw specific code.
And then we'll go over the
machine learning specific code.
So that is attentive low classification
class and in the classifier class,
which it calls as the lowest level,
the classification class. Okay.
So once we've done that, then we'll
be able to compile and run our model.
So let's, let's start,
let's start off here, right?
So here's the model link to it.
It's in the description.
Check it out if you haven't yet.
Uh, okay. So let's see here.
We have
this main activity.
So, and by the way, I have commented
every single line in this code.
So there is no excuse to not,
uh, learn how this code works.
Even if you don't listen to this video,
check out the link.
Every single line is commented very
well. Okay? Even the dependencies. So
what we're going to do is in the
main activity we're going to,
uh, we're going to define the main
activity. So that sounds counterintuitive.
We're going to define the only view
that the user, uh, deals with, right?
Which is this one in the XML file,
right?
This is it right here.
So the user will,
in this box right here,
we'll draw with their finger,
the number,
and then he'll hit,
they'll hit the test button.
And then in this text you see
the classes here we've got,
we've got three classes
we've got to draw you.
That's where the user draws the number.
And then we've got this button,
this clear button, which will, which
will clear the canvas if we want.
We've got this detect button,
which is going to perform inference.
So it's going to take that image as input,
send it to our tensorflow
model,
through the tensor flow tension
flows through the android Sdk,
which can access the tensor flow
c Plus c plus plus file on device.
And it's going to return the outputs
and it's going to return that output and
it's going to output it inside of
this text to you. Okay? So that's,
that's like what the visualization looks
like. It's a one view app. Very simple.
And so, and here are trained
models, by the way, write this.
We've got to train models
and not just to train models.
We have a set of labels,
right?
Zero through nine so that we know what
are the possible class labels cause this
is a multi-class classification problem.
And so we've got to train models,
one for Ken Ross and one for tension
flow and we'll be using the care os one
just because, uh, why not? But the
tensor flow one would probably be,
will be more accurate, but it
takes longer to train. Okay.
So let's go into this main activity and
look at what the, what is happening here,
right? So we're going to
import a bunch of, um,
drawing classes.
By the way,
the activity is how the user interacts
with the android architecture.
With the android APP. Almost all
activities interact with the user.
So the activity class takes care
of creating a window for you,
which you can place or Ui,
which in which you can place your
Ui with the set content view.
When we initialize it in the, uh, on
create function, right? Right here.
Okay.
So you know,
if the more complex your happies the
more activities that you would have,
we've got one activity and that activity
is drawing the number and hitting the
teks or hitting clear and repeating that.
That's the only activity.
And in this activity, all of those actions
are encapsulated. So we've got that.
And then, uh, we've got a
bunch of other dependencies.
Each of them is going to be
used for classification as
well as drawing elements,
right?
So it's split basically the dependencies
either draw what we're looking for or
let me make this bigger.
Can I make it better?
Yes, yes I can. You can
do anything that you dream
unless it's crazy. Well,
even then you could, uh,
with the right amount of computation
and training. Okay. Okay.
So let's see. Okay, so now
let's look at the main activity.
So for the main activity, we've
got our UI elements, right?
Those buttons that I just showed
you as well as the views, right?
We've got it set up views and got the UI
elements and we've got our coordinates.
So let's talk about each
of these in an order. Okay,
so the pixel width is the width
of our image 28 by 28 pixels.
The button. All right,
we've got two buttons.
The class button is the detect button.
The clear button is a clear button.
The text view is what app,
which shows the output.
And the m classifiers is an array list,
which is an array with some, you know,
it's, it's basically built on top
of the array class. Yeah, it's a,
it's a list of so you can perform, you
know, getters and setters on an array.
Uh, and so it's a list of
classifiers ever we're going to use.
So the reason that they list is because
we're going to use to classifiers and
this and this repository, not
just one. We're going to use two,
one for tennis as low and one for care
Os. So we can compare the results, right?
So that's why it's an array list.
And then we've got our views, right?
So we've got our draw view, which is the
big view and we've got our draw model,
which is the smaller version
where the user actually draws.
And then we've got our set of points and
these are coordinance that the user is,
is tapping that the user taps.
Okay.
And then we've got the private
set of coordinates, which
is like a copy of those.
But internally that we can then
modify inside of this class,
but they're not exposed to publicly.
So other classes can't interact with them.
And this is just good
programming practice too,
to have your doc to have your variables
that are not going to interact with
other classes, set them to privates
because you know, otherwise
things can happen that you don't expect
where you're calling a class but it's
not. And then it's going
to modify some variables.
But because you haven't said it's
private, it's going to, yeah,
because you haven't set that
some variables to private.
It's going to modify those variables
and you don't want that to happen,
so you have to set them to private.
Okay?
So we've got that and now
and our on create method,
which is like the basic building
block for an activity class,
it's going to run only once for the
entire lifecycle of the activity, right?
And we've got a bunch of these activities,
specific lifecycle methods,
but the first one is on create and it
just runs once. Okay. So we've got that.
And so now let's go ahead and
create an instance for this,
for this main activity. And once we
have that, we're going to say, okay,
so let's get that drawing view.
So we, we define this in Xmls,
we're going to call it by its ID that
we define an XML store in drawing.
You do the same for the model.
And then we're going to set the model.
So we're going to take that view and
set its model to that draw models,
super missile,
encapsulating it inside of that view.
And then we're going to create an entouch
listener to activate whenever the user
taps it. And then, uh,
we're also gonna do the same for the
clear button as well as the detect button.
Okay. And then we're going to
do it for the view. So this is,
this is just us wiring
our XML to our class,
our program out of class so we
can then manipulate these values.
And then we've got a
couple of functions here.
We've got our own resumed
function, which is, you know,
assuming that the user has
gone, gone, gone out of the APP,
it's going to call this
and call these methods,
which basically it's a way of saving
our state and making sure that our APP
doesn't crash. And these are
just, uh, basically like, um,
they're like exceptions.
They're like android wide exception rules.
So it's like saving where we are.
And so we've got that.
And now let's load our model.
So this is going to create a model object
in memory using the same tensorflow
proto buff model file,
which contains all of the learn weights.
So it's going to take these weights and
it's what you saved them into this m
classifiers array list array.
So we can then use them.
So it takes those saved weights in local
storage on android device and saves
them into memories. So it's an in
memory array list that we can then, um,
perform inference with.
And so we have a try catch function
for that because if they're not there,
then we have to say, hey, there's an error
initializing these classifiers. Okay.
So then we've got this,
uh, on click methods.
So this is whenever the user clicks
on anything. So we have a bunch of,
if then statements to define where
if the user clicks what happens.
So if the user clicks the clear button,
then we have to clear the model,
reset it and invalidate any
new entries the user does.
And then we set the text to empty
like nothing is there anymore.
Now if the user clicks
the, uh, classified button,
then we're going to take
the array of pixels, right?
So we get the pixel data of everything
that a user has drawn up to that point.
And we store it in a pixel
array and then we say, okay,
we'll initialize a string is empty because
we're later going to fill it with the
help of prediction. And then
we're going to say, okay,
so for each of the classifiers, for
both tensorflow and chaos, recognize.
And so I'll, I'll, I'll show you
what this recognized function does,
but recognize or classify what those set
of pixels bar, you know, a zero, a one,
a two or three. What, what is this? What,
what did they use or draw and then
take that label. And if it's empty,
then I'll an NEC, um, a question
mark. If it's not empty,
then output the label and set
that into the text. Phew. Okay.
So that's the highest
level of what is happening.
And so now we've got this entouch method,
which when the user moves their finger,
draw a line accordingly in
that direction. Okay? So,
so we take the action and
we store it as an integer.
And the actions all have predefined in,
uh, like in memory or not in memory, but,
uh, that, that are a part of
android. So check this out.
So if the action that the user has,
so basically if the user
has touched the screen,
which we defined with motion events,
action down, which is a zero.
See these are all
predefined and Androids Sdk.
So basically if the user has touched
the screen, again drawing the line,
but if a user has moved, if the
user has started moving, then uh,
start then start actually drawing
the line in a different direction.
So touching it just initializes
the line drawing and moving.
It actually begins drawing
the line more than just a dot.
And then if a finger is lifted,
action up, then stop drawing.
Okay, so then, uh, these are,
these are the implementations of
these functions that we just find the,
the price touchdown as well as the press.
Such move. So for the press touchdown,
we get the coordinates of
wherever the user has touched,
calculate those positions in memory,
and then start drawing the line using
where we were before and where we are now.
And then in this main drawing function,
this is when the user is
actually moving their finger.
Take both of those sets of coordinates,
where we were before and where we are now.
And then draw a line between those two
points and keep doing that every time.
Okay. So yeah, and then for press such up,
we just take draw models
and line function,
which is going to help us
stop drawing the line. Okay.
So that's the main activity.
And so notice how we had the straw model
function that is continuously used all
over the place. So let's look at
what's happening there, right?
What is happening in the
straw model function? Well,
in the draw model function
we are,
okay,
so we are drawing the model.
That's what we're doing in
the draw model function.
So it's a collection of getter and setter
functions that we can use later on to
draw a character model. So we'll
initialize it with a line element,
which is a, it's just two
values, the x and y coordinates.
And then we'll have an internal
representation as well to manipulate those
values.
So we'll manipulate them and then we'll
return those manipulated values back to
the public x y values. So then we can
then draw them on XML in the XML file.
So for a single line,
so we have a private line class
align consists of elements. Okay.
So we have a model, a model consists of
lines and align consists of elements.
Okay. So what is uh, so let
me talk about each of these.
An element is the line from
point a to point B, right?
So there are a bunch of
elements in a single line.
Align is everything that you draw from
when you start to when you finish.
So aligned to be an entire number.
Or it could be like, you know,
you draw the first, Oh that's aligned and
then you draw the rest of the, you know,
if you're trying to draw a six [inaudible]
oh and then you are the, you know,
the curve.
Both of those are two lines and inside
each of those lines or set of elements
right? From point a to point B. So
that's, and then all of that is a model.
Okay. The draw model. Okay.
So model line element.
That's the of of what this looks like.
Object hierarchy. Okay. So we've got that.
And so now let's
talk about these other functions.
So this is our current line
are the width and height of,
of that line, height of that line. And
then we have the list of lines, right?
So inside of a model there are lines
and inside of the lines there aren't
elements. So we're defining a
raise for each of these objects.
And so we've got to set a getter and
setter functions for each of them. Okay?
So start line and line, add line elements,
get the sides of it, get the line,
and then clear. Okay, so
that's it for our draw model.
And then we've got draw a renderer.
So we're,
so we're going down even lower level.
So we're going down the
rabbit hole of lines.
Okay?
So for our draw a renderer class,
we're going to say let's draw
all these lines to a canvas.
So we've got our render model. And so this
is just straight up drawing functions.
So this is the straight up
drawing function. So all of those
functions that we define in this main
activity as well as Deidre model,
they are high level functions.
They're not actually drawing them to XML.
This is how we're programmatically
deciding what drawing looks like.
This is how we decided
with drawing looks like.
But then in this draw a render function,
we take all of that programmatic
logic and we apply it to XML.
So we're going to directly manipulate
XML elements in this class or so we're
essentially drawing lines on canvas.
So we'll first set this set anti alias,
um,
function to true because we want
to minimize distortion artifacts.
It's just good practice to do.
And then we get the sides of the line
to draw. And then given that side,
we create a for loop. So get the
whole line from the model object,
set its color to black and then get the
first of many lines that make up the
overall line. So we get the element
size and we say that's a single element.
And if the element size is less than one,
that means that the user hasn't drawn
anything. So just skip it. But if it,
if these, if the user has then
store that in an element object,
get the coordinates of, of the, of that
element object, the x and y coordinates.
And so for each coordinate in the lines
of for all of the elements in the line,
we have a set of elements in an array,
right for a single line,
each of those elements and the coordinates
and then draw them on the canvas
using where we were before,
where we are now.
And then this paints a object which
is going to create, make those,
make that drawing black.
And then we,
and then we make the new law
that we make the new coordinates,
the old coordinates in this
last x and laughs wife function.
And so that's draw renderer and now
we'll go to the lowest level for drawing,
which is draw a view.
So for draw view,
I mean this is almost like unnecessary
to go over because it's so low level I,
this is just one of those classes that
you should just import and like not even
worry about because there's not really
any machine learning specific knowledge
here. But I'll go over anyway.
Just had a high level. Uh,
we want to first a reset the use,
so it's empty to empty the drying.
So we'll hit this reset function,
which is going to take that bit map
image of whatever the user drew, drew,
and then empty, empty out all the
pixel values so they're not black.
So they're white again. And then,
uh, this is the set up function.
It's a private function where we define
the views size, the size of the models,
bitmap,
and then scale it.
So it's properly scaled for whatever
android device that you're on. Again,
this would be automatic, like ios
would do this automatically, uh, but,
and when the user begins drawing,
initialize a model,
render class and draw it on the canvas.
So this is where we,
this is where we initialize that draw a
render a class that we just talked about.
This is where we take it and we,
we apply it.
And so then we draw, it's
whatever, whatever it drew,
whatever it says to draw,
we then draw it.
And then we kept,
so the rest of these are
basically calculating the
position of the finger on the
screen. So very, very detailed. X,
y coordinates of where your
finger is on the screen.
And then we draw the
canvas using the bitmap,
which is the image that we just drew.
We release it, which is just memory,
a memory management.
And so we released it from memory using
this recycling function because android
uses garbage collection,
which is a type of memory
management technique.
So apple uses retain cycles and
android uses garbage collection.
Okay.
Two different methods.
Garbage collection is happening.
I'm refreshing my mobile knowledge here.
Garbage collection is
happening at runtime as um,
automatic reference counting on high
west is happening at compiled time.
That's difference. Uh,
so which one's better?
There are pros and cons of both.
That's out of the scope of this.
This is about machine learning,
but if you guys want more,
let me know of this stuff because I've
done mobile development quite a bit
before. Okay. So, uh, so then we
get the pixel data and then we,
for the potential floats input. So this
is how we define the pixel. You know,
every single pixel, we
have a for loop, we're t,
we're going to every single pixel and
we're storing it in that pixel array.
So for all of those other functions,
we can use that pixel array for both draw,
model, draw renderer, uh, and even this,
this, this function drop drove you.
Okay? So that's for all
of the uh, view logic.
And now let's talk about the
machine learning specific logic.
So it's are at the highest level, which
is our tensorflow classification class,
and then our classifier, and then
our classification class. Okay?
So for tens of classification we'll say,
how does this work?
Okay,
so why don't you have android native
native android from a bunch of standard
hint android development kit
Sdk, Sdk, functionality is being,
is being important here.
And then we've got this interface.
So remember that c plus plus file
that I talked about right here,
this is what we import it. Okay? So
this is coming directly from Google.
This is what they wrote as the bridge
between tensorflow c plus plus an android.
We import it right here.
Maybe by Google. Okay.
And so what we're going to do is
we're going to implement this class.
So this class that we're going to create
is an implementation of classifier.
Wait,
what is classifier classifier is the
public interface for how our APP interacts
with the classifier. Okay? So that
so publicly we give it a string.
So whatever we name it as well
as the recognize function,
that is the one public function that we
are making visible to all the rest of
the APP. The recognized function, which
just going to take the pixel array,
has input of the image and then return
the classification. And like the output,
this is a zero 26% chance, zero. You know,
for what's a hundred minus 26 74% chance,
not zero or at 74% percent
chance one or whatever it is.
So
yeah,
so it's an implementation of that. So
that's the interface for this class. Okay.
So what we're gonna do is we're
going to say, okay, so this is old.
This is the threshold that we defined.
So it only returns if it's
at least this confidence,
it's gotta be at least 10% confidence of
what it's looking at. And if it's not,
don't return anything,
right?
It's gotta be at least 10% confident of
whatever output probability that it's
predicting.
And so we have a set of variables here
that we're going to talk about when we
implement them. So let's just go
through each of these functions.
So the first function is the read
labels function. So given a saved,
drawn model,
let's read all the classification labels
that are stored and write them to our
in memory labels list. So remember
we have this, um, classification.
Where is it?
Okay
labeled file right here. You know, so
this is what we read it into memory.
So into memory, we say.
So for all those labels,
initialize them as an array list,
read them,
add them to our Ra and return those
labels. That's what that does.
So this is the, uh, this is the
second most important function. This,
this recognizes the first most important,
but as the second most important.
And so what this does is given a model,
okay,
so given a model and it's
labeled file and as Metadata,
let's fill out a class of our object with
all of the necessary made it Metadata,
including the output prediction,
right?
So these are all the attributes of the
model that we can basically get to inset
later on.
So we've got a name that we defined,
we've got the input by name for the input.
So okay,
so we've got a name for the model.
We have a name for input data,
we have her name for help,
a prediction.
We have art labels that we just read
right from, from storage into memory.
And then we have the models path that we,
and that's where the,
that's where all the raw assets, asset
files, car, as well as where the model is.
And so that's what he's inner
inference comes into play, right?
That comes from Google.
Look, this, all this stuff.
This is how we take data and feed it
to the model. This is the gateway.
This class is 10 or tensorflow inference.
Interface class is the
gateway between Androids,
Java functionality and tension flows,
c plus plus functionality maybe by Google.
And so this is what we define what that
is and we'll send it to the TF helper
attribute. And so how big is the
input? Well, we'll define that.
We'll pre allocate a buffer for the pro
bowl. Those outputs that come out, right,
it's not going to just one output. This
is a multi-class classification problem.
We have a set of outputs,
so stored in the hall and an array list.
Okay, so then, so that's the
second most important class.
And then remember this public class,
we're just exposing the name,
the string that we define.
And this is the first most important,
not class function. This is the first
most important function class function,
do op, Dutch, English. I'm just switching
between languages and my mind is like,
okay, so then for our recognized class,
which is the most important class,
here's how it works. Using the
interface, we give them the input name,
the raw pixels from the
drawing and the input size.
So we feed that into our tensorflow
flow interface, right? That class.
And then we check the probability
values. So we say, okay,
if we want to keep those probability,
if we want to keep those
probability values in memory,
which is why it's a bullying,
then feed it that those probabilities as
an array of probabilities, which we do,
which, so we're going to send it to true
and then we get the possible outputs.
So when we run it, we s we set
these output named as the perimeter,
so it's going to fill
those applique values. Um,
so then we get the possible outputs
using the names which are here,
and
this is where we pre allocate the buffer.
So that, so then we get those possible
outputs, uh, via the fetch method.
So we first run using those output
names and then we fetch it. Okay.
So we take the actual
output and the output names,
which is the list that
we fill with the output,
whatever the output prediction is,
we fill it into that output names a list.
And then we find the best classification
from those outputs. So we say,
let's initialize our
classification object,
and then we say find the
best classification for each
of the output predictions.
If it's above the threshold
that we defined for accuracy,
right it out to the view in
that text view. So we say, okay,
for the length of each output,
print out the output,
print out the labels just
for us for debugging.
And then if the outputs is
greater than the threshold,
hit the prediction value of the output
is greater than the, than the threshold.
Okay. And it's greater than, uh, the, uh,
yeah,
the output.
And it's greater than the Alpha
prediction that we defined inside of that
classification object.
Then update the object with
the new output and it's label.
And then we can write to
memory. Well, first of all,
return it and then we'll write right
to memory when we call it. Okay. So
yeah, so we talked about our classifier
and our classification class.
Okay. So one more thing, right? So
the classification class itself,
we've got two variables.
COMP is the output prediction
and the label is the input level.
And so we define the threshold
here. You know, w 1.0,
which is 10% the minimum threshold.
And then the label, which is no,
and the only public facing function
is this update function. Oh.
And the get label and the get comp.
So we to get her functions
and then an update function,
which is how we update it, which
we called right here. Right.
And that's it. So yeah, if
you have an android device,
you can easily deploy it to that. Right.
Just compile it and then pick one. Oh,
so I'm going to talk about one more thing.
When would you use a model on your
device versus on the server? Uh,
you would use it on the server if you
want to constantly deploy new versions of
a model. So you'd use tensorflow
serving, right? The con to that, right.
Because the con to that is then you would
need your mobile device to constantly
make HTP requests. So it always has
to be connected to the Internet.
What you could do is you
can have it both ways.
So the best of both worlds would be to
have an inference model on the device,
which is static,
right?
You can't just update it once you
deploy a new version of the APP.
So the user would have to update the APP,
but you could have a version on the APP
and you can have a version on the server
that is constantly updated that you can
set some frequency to check and then
update the model locally using the server.
So you should have the
best of both worlds. Okay.
So let me answer two questions to end
this and then we're done. We're done.
So the two questions are,
can you do a video that's like Siri,
like how to code the Siri Product.
So I could think about apple is they
don't really open source anything, right?
So we don't actually know what their
machine learning, like how it works.
I'm going to bet though that it's okay.
Like it's not that good comparatively
because in this day and age,
if you want respect,
if you want credibility,
the name of the game is to publish and
publish often. And apple doesn't do that.
Uh,
but how does Siri work?
I'm going to guess that it's going
to use a set of predefined, um,
responses on a server
making http requests.
It's barely using any machine learning.
Maybe it's using machine learning just to,
um,
well it isn't using machine
learning to detect your speech,
but I don't think it's using machine
learning to generate responses. If it is,
I'd be very surprised. Uh, yeah,
so that's the first question.
And then one more question is
how to train feedback and get their
respective ratings predicted rating of new
feedback. So that's a supervised
classification problem, right?
You've got some texts and if you've got
a label and then you went to one of the
mapping between the two. And so how
do you learn the mapping between two,
like a label and an input? Uh,
supervised classification, right?
This just general classification.
The way you do this for text
is using an LSTM network,
which is a type of recurring net
made for more or for text data.
Cool. Please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I've got to create a new series,
so thanks for watching.